it's kind of fascinating to me about the
technological moment we've been in for
the last half century or so is you know
it emerged out of a culture of
relationship with the planet that sort
of expected nature to always be there
and we've given ourselves this kind of
this kind of space to create without
reckoning the full cost and now but
lated lee we're realizing that that
there is a cost that needs to be
accounted for an address and so you know
a lot of the thinking that i'm doing now
is you know actually how to bring these
seemingly very disparate worlds of
attention to the natural world
and attention to media and technology
more closely together and not just to
tell the stories of plants and other
organisms because media is very good at
doing that
but what does it mean that these things
inhabit the same world how do we create
a Technosphere an information society a
world of media that takes the planet
into account that's kind of the question
that's it's foremost in my mind these
days
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are at Harvard Kennedy School in the
beautiful Cambridge Massachusetts we are
now going to be talking about time and
memory in the digital humanities and
beyond
we have matthew battles joining us on
the show hello Alan thank you so much
for coming on really appreciate I look
forward to the conversation likewise
Matthew's background is so awesome he's
the associate director of meta lab at
Harvard where he studies the impact of
digital technology on the humanities
over a twenty three year writing career
he has authored four books on the
subjects of the survival and destruction
of knowledge the tale of students
scholars and staff who give a great
library its life the history of writing
from Mesopotamia to multimedia and most
recently on trees alliance and
entanglement with humanity from
antiquity to present and you can find
Matthews links below has met a lab
Harvard link below as well as his
Twitter link as well so let's jump into
things from our perspective of we are
finder SOSUS to
words of Earth what is your current take
on the state of our world wow that's a
big question to open with and it's
definitely a question that I've been
thinking about a lot and particularly
our relationship as a species with the
planet you know which is a fraud topic
it's a fraud question because there are
a lot of different ways of being human
you know and I think when we think about
the impact we're having on the planet
we're thinking about kind of one sector
of humanity at one time pre-eminently
right the west and modernity the
technological moment the great
acceleration of the last you know less
than a century a very narrow slice of
human life that has had this decisive
impact on the planet on ourselves as a
species certainly but also on the rest
of the life we share this planet with so
a lot of my work currently is thinking
about that from a humanities perspective
hardly the only one who's doing this the
humanities discovered you know in the
last quarter century that oh there's a
planet that the humanities happens on
and and and the species lives on right
and so you know a lot of folks who spend
a lot of time in libraries and archives
are now waking up to a different sense
of responsibility also I think a
different sense of possibility to bring
those tools of memory and reflection of
argumentation and critique to bear in
impactful ways on the ways in which we
think about our relationship with the
planet almost as though the awareness
has come back to the humanities after
the Industrial Revolution and
exponential technology age that we've
come that we've built and come through
yeah you know I think that in the modern
era we sort of humanities ceded that
round to science and there was this
classic sort of split you know that was
after see peace know a scientist in the
mid twentieth century a British
scientist wrote this essay called the
two cultures or he identified the split
between the humanities and the physical
sciences a split that had emerged you
know in history long before that but
which really came to a head and
20th century a lot of humanities folks
said you should leave all that stuff to
the folks in the sciences to worry about
you know that the cosmos life and the
planet and the material things of the
world and focus on the imagination focus
on you know symbol and idea and
archetype and memory and we stopped
thinking about those things as really
knit together and the way they have been
for members of our species for a much
longer period of time than this narrow
sort of two cultures split might
indicate at times it definitely feels
like there is a segregation into
engineers and scientists and then
artists and it they work so closely
together there's so much overlap that
has happened with the Industrial
Revolution up until exponential
technology agents happen but why only
now with the proliferation of AI and
stuck biology and all these other issues
that we're having are we finally going
like hmm what is that humanities how
does that have to do with what's
happening right now
yeah yeah it's a funny question an
interesting question and I think it
might have to do with the way in which
is the technology seems to be escaping
our control in certain kinds of ways I
mean at a certain level that's a kind of
marketing ploy it's a way to it's a way
to describe technology that gives
technology a lot of power but there's
something substantial behind it as well
particularly in the context of machine
learning and these other kind of you
know algorithmically powered means of
statistical prediction and inference we
think of them increasingly as kind of
natural phenomena you know they've been
talked about as techniques that get us
beyond needing to actually come up with
ideas and theorize you have enough data
you have the right tools you set the
tools loose on the data and they will
tell the stories and make the arguments
and and maybe that begins to feel a
little out of control for everybody in a
way that makes the humanities useful
refreshing and perhaps
you know a source of insight so what the
effective by which I mean sort of the
emotional as well as the ethical
dimensions of those technologies might
be it's just it's so interesting talking
to you about this it just feels as
though we've been making the technology
flower and then we finally realize holy
cow humans not even really in controlled
technology and then we look at maybe
religion or some sort of humanities or
some sort of transcendent thing that
that gives us potentially a deeper sense
of why we built that technology why
we're not in control of it where we're
actually going from here yeah okay let's
get into the journey Matthew so how did
you get even hooked into writing for you
know 23 years and being the associate
director here at Harvard's metal lab so
how how did this process happen from
you're young oh sure sure well I mean
for me that sort of fusion of the
humanities and the sciences comes pretty
naturally because these things have
always sorted you know been engaged in a
struggle for control over my imagination
I mean I you know from a very early age
I wanted to be a writer I was drawn to
writing and the arts at the same time
you know the wonders of the natural
world were a kind of constant importance
to me my favorite trip as a child was to
go to Chicago I grew up just outside of
Chicago we'd go in and go to the
museum's you know and the combination of
the museum's which are all within a nice
walk from each other in Chicago the you
know Chicago Art Institute the Museum of
Natural History the Shedd Aquarium you
know to go from sort of the wonders of
you know visual culture and the ways in
which humans have expressed themselves
through art to you know giant you know
skeletons of dinosaurs and also
collections of you know human cultures
through time at the Natural History
Museum to the Shedd Aquarium with this
kind of jewel box of fish shimmering in
the dark you know that was very
evocative for me that that cluster so it
wasn't only like the sciences and
humanities but also the context of the
museum that exerted a big fascination on
me at the same time if you know that you
know
kind of museum scape in Chicago it's
right along the lakefront and you know
this big cold forbidding you know abyss
of water also beckoned and so the
natural world itself and it's kind of
uncanny other nests from us and yet it's
intimacy it's swirling around us all the
time that was all part of the mix as
well so with that background I ended up
in college starting out thinking that I
would study evolutionary biology which
took me to the anthropology department
but it was the social anthropology that
began to appeal to me more and in
particular questions about how we
imagined and what kinds of meanings we
ascribe to those phenomena that I was
just talking about why do we put those
things in museums and not other things
do other people in the world put the
same things in museums that we do these
are the sorts of questions that began to
appeal to me through all of that was the
sense that the best way I had for
getting control over all of that was by
writing about it and so finishing up an
undergraduate degree in anthropology
particularly at the time I was doing
that in the early 90s was a time when a
lot of anthropologists thought of
themselves as mostly writers they think
they called themselves anthropologists
to gain some kind of authority or or
expertise in the world but really what
they were just doing was writing about
their experience I thought okay well
maybe I can just be a writer then and
dispense with the whole expertise and
authority side of things so I did a
graduate degree in in creative writing
focusing on fiction but also had
wonderful exposure to poetry and and
playwriting in a graduate program and
creative writing at Boston University
finishing that up I sort of felt like
you know I needed a good place to be
while trying to start writing about
things in the world the library seemed
like a good place to be in writer and so
I got a job at Widener Library at
Harvard which you know as well as being
a kind of you know preeminent
mmm a very powerful institution of
higher learning it's also just like when
you live in the Boston area it's like
another big employer you know so like
they had jobs in
the library I thought what could be
better than to be you know in the midst
of the library sort of I thought I'd
just be shelving books you know and
thinking about the things that I wanted
to be thinking about but the library
very quickly became a kind of focus
fascination for me in a way I started to
think of myself as an anthropologist and
the tribe that I was studying was the
you know the librarians but also the
technologists students the scholars who
used the library so the library quickly
switched from being you know an
accommodating milieu for being a
creative person to being the topic of my
creativity so that's how that transition
and it was made it happened for me at
the very same time that some will
remember Nicholson Baker author and
novelist was writing in The New Yorker
about the demise of the card catalog in
libraries so this was like 1997-98 the
the world wide web was just emerging we
were just seeing you know mosaic turn
into Netscape just beginning as a
culture to kind of accommodate ourselves
to thought of being networked with each
other digitally and that was having a
big impact on the library and Nicholson
Baker was one author who was writing
critically about what are we losing when
the card catalog is taken away and all
we have left our computers and being in
the library at the time I thought you
know I realized because you see the
whole archaeology of of how libraries
have organized themselves over time
particularly an older and big research
library linked Widener I thought this
has happened again and again and again
this is not the first time that
libraries have gone through a
technological revolution and so I became
fascinated in that kind of archaeology
of the structures of knowledge
organization and dissemination in the
library as well so that's how I got from
you know wandering along the lakefront
in Chicago to wondering about how
libraries are put together what they
meant to us in different times of places
and what the future might hold for them
as well I love when you're describing
being a kid and going between the
museum's I think that that's something
that we hopefully can get more parents
and children to do together because it
gives a very multidisciplinary
upgrade to the to the world view when
you can pop between the different
museums as well see the big Lake
Michigan as well and yeah it's so yeah
different than the skyscrapers right
next to it yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure
yeah and I keep looking for that Museum
that has all of that stuff together yeah
but it's nice to have to walk from one
to the other - yes yeah they're
specialized in the sense they're still
multidisciplinary but specialized yeah
yeah and then also in the story it's
great that you found yourself being you
know in and in the employment with with
Harvard because then in especially in
the library because then you end up
realizing the like you said this
technological transition how it affects
a library and then also you're
interested in you know well one human
takes months or years of their life to
synthesize their worldview into an
eight-hour read and then there's like
millions of those eight-hour reasons
available her people yeah and so then it
becomes a very interesting compression
algorithm for knowledge and so yeah so
then this is yeah yeah yeah that's a
good point and it's a compression
algorithm also for all of those readings
as well I mean I like that image of a
book as a kind of concentration of you
know intellectual imaginary creative
flavor and there are a lot of other
people involved with that too and I mean
that changes over time you know there
are times when a book is really a
product of one person but there are many
kinds of books that are the product and
many many people and also the way those
books end up on the shelves and
organized on the shelves and there are
ways to find them to discover them to to
relate them to each other
all of those are like technologies as
well that lots of people are involved
with right and the the relationship of
those books on the shelf that's a story
that's an argument as well and so
thinking of the library as you know
almost a fractal kind of compaction or
expression
many different kinds of intellectual
labor as well as physical labor as well
as the you know distribution of
materials I mean the mind really boggles
when you think about you know how many
different kinds of activity are
organized in the thing we call a book
yeah yeah and it's also nuts thinking
about how we can we could go and partake
in the millions of books within the
library and now we and that used to be
kind of like a little community and now
we're with our newsfeed our news
newsfeed and our social network newsfeed
that these things are can just be
browsed from the chair in the home and
yeah and with what is the
signal-to-noise ratio and yeah these are
questions of humanity right right we're
really trying and we've been trying to
sort that out now for for a while I mean
and depending on how you define the
terms you know we've been trying to sort
that out for you know since the 2016
election or since the advent of social
media or since the advent of the World
Wide Web or maybe since you know the
rise of a professional class of news
reporters and commentators on the world
which gets us back a couple of hundred
years or maybe the invention of the
printing press or maybe it's the
invention of writing which takes us back
5,000 years you know but in each of
those stages you know people had to
contend with questions about their
relationship with the mass of stuff
called knowledge who has control over it
who is access to it who gets to
participate in its creation and it's a
its management its administration we've
had so many different ways to configure
that you know and I think it's been
commented on many times in the history
of the West you know in the 18th century
people thought oh all of these new books
that are getting printed printing press
makes it so easy the bar to authorship
Authority expertise is now so much lower
people saw that as problematic then in a
way that I think is very recognized
to us today in terms of you know asking
questions about who has authority to
tell stories about public experience and
then the democratization actually in
many ways become fan of really important
and great and so yet this is this is you
I like I also really like how you take
us back 5,000 years to writing and then
you take us to the digital technology
it's just kind of the span of what
you've been also writing and interested
in let's let's go ahead and do exactly
that cool so let's go into let's do
library so one of the first books and
this is this is really cool from from
Alexandria at the Library of Alexandria
to the Internet and the preservation the
inspiration the obliteration of
knowledge yeah it's a big story and and
it was kind of overwhelming to start
taking that on the story of the library
because libraries not only you know like
a place you go to get books but it's a
like an institution so it's got a power
it's got a politics to it there are
people in charge there are people who
are in or out and that changes over time
it's also an archetype right I mean we
think about the library as a kind of
symbol for from memory for expertise you
know that that oh that person she's like
a library right and so you know it's got
it's kind of a mythic weight to it it's
got a lot of cultural baggage attached
to it it's got a power dynamic and a
politics associated with it and it's
changed a great deal over that sweep of
time libraries have really existed in a
way since you know since writing came
into being but I've got a friend
Jessamine West is her name she's a
technologist in librarian in Vermont
and she speaks very intelligently about
the rules technology plays in libraries
today and you know she's she likes to
look at those little free libraries you
know that you see on on like bird like
birdhouses you know in neighborhoods
wonderful things but she says you know
that's not really a little Free Library
that's a little free
book box because a library has
librarians in it a library has people
who know where the books are and where
they came from
and they can help you find them and you
know that's a very I think you know
powerful and expansive definition of
what a library is not just a set of
books but also you know a community of
readers and a community of people who
know how to help put those readers in
touch with the books but that's also an
image of the library that has a history
I mean you know the public library that
we sort of take for granted as a civic
institution in the u.s. in particular
hasn't been around all that long you
know and even today and a lot of places
that feel fully participating in the
modern world in other kinds of ways in
many other societies the idea of you
know a town or a neighborhood or a city
having a public library where anybody
can go and take books and take them home
with them and bring them back whenever
they feel like it that's not it's not
universally available and so you know
that also implies that there may be a
time when that doesn't exist anymore and
that's where you know a certain amount
of a kind of political cultural anxiety
we have about the library comes from as
well they're very you know robust
institutions but also ephemeral I feel
so much anxiety about losing libraries
yeah yeah yeah and I want to know what
is your take on the the power dynamics
that I've heard from the burning of
Alexandria yeah yeah sure sure I mean
you know libraries because they're
repositories of knowledge they become
you know tokens in games of power and I
mean in the ancient world in particular
when you know the forms of the expertise
and authority were difficult to develop
but also where the material that writing
went on to was expensive it was a matter
of craft it took a long time to make
books and you could only make a few of
them at a time so you know they were
very much part of the administration of
power in the ancient world and
you know so they become tokens in kind
of games of power and you know the story
of the Library of Alexandria which is a
story that I explore in library uncle in
history is really an interesting one
because it has both the dimensions of
the library as a symbol as a kind of
mythic entity and as an actual
institution in the world part of empires
that change hands or change their shape
over time we think of the library as
something that got burned and of course
there were some burnings involved but
the Library of Alexandria as an
institution had had a life that spanned
millennia I mean it was hundreds and
hundreds of years and that library waxed
and waned over time it grew and it
receded its role in society changed very
early on it was primarily a repository
for
scholarship about Homer's and story it's
the Iliad and the Odyssey it became a
repository for poetry than scientific
knowledge in the ancient world and was
also attached to an academy and
institution of learning so it changed
hands it changed rules and its fortunes
went up and down many times throughout
its history and that's true of many of
these you know institutions you know
libraries we think of as places where we
put the books in order to preserve them
one of the ironies of that is it makes
them very easy to destroy it's easy to
destroy a whole bunch of books yeah a
whole lot of the acquired knowledge of a
culture not only knowledge of you know
the sciences of poetry of divinity but
also memory you know the ways people
attach themselves to these books and the
institutions that hold them you know as
we've seen even recently in you know
Wars in North Africa or in the Balkans
in the 90s you know enemies target the
libraries of one another the archives
as well as the neighborhoods as well as
the institution's as well as the
military infrastructure and that's been
you know libraries have been victims of
that dynamic all along a library being
able to last multiple generations is
very interesting that you're pointing
out even hundreds of years also that
what makes it a target is that it is
such a kind of a capture of the brain
and heart and soul essence of periods of
time of the edge of knowledge of what
was in parts of culture so this is a
very important way to view what
libraries are and to not necessarily
just brush things off because we now are
giving children smartphones their whole
lives so to take a child into the
library and to really put this knowledge
that you're teaching right now and equip
them with it I think it's creative yet
yeah yeah you know I'm thinking about
how a few years ago I remember points
even Johnson made about games that I
think might be pertinent here a few
years ago in a book I can't remember
which one Stephen Johnson wrote that you
know digital games are much more
exciting to him than then a lot of board
games are because they introduce young
children in particular to you know
digital ways of knowing and digital
media to manipulate and he in particular
pointed out shoots shoots know Candyland
Candyland was the one he pointed to and
he said you know I would rather have my
like preliterate child playing on an
iPad than playing Candyland which is
just this game that you know that it
doesn't really there's no
decision-making involved you just pick
up a card and you go where it tells you
to go and I thought you know I
understand that I mean it's interesting
Candyland which if you're not familiar
with it it's just you know it's a kind
of track game and you have players you
have tokens and and you pick up a card
and you go to the next color of that
card right so in a way you shuffle the
deck and the game's kind of already done
and you're just finding out how it how
it how it plays but if you think about
playing that game the three-year-old
the five-year-old what else are they
getting from that
counter they're getting a sense of
taking turns of playing fair you know of
all of the kind of social demands that
come with sitting around a board game
with other people and and agreeing to
get along for that space of play you can
get that in digital context but the but
the face to face encounter remains
important for human beings to be able to
master and in a way a library can be a
place where that same kind of encounter
can take place yes we have digital tools
are very powerful and there's something
about a place where we come together and
share access to knowledge and resources
where we learn to take turns where we
learn to borrow and put things back I
mean these are very simple ethics but
having the kind of rich complicated
messy encounter with them in shared
space remains vital and libraries can
provide that now it's important to
remember at the same time that that's
we're talking about a particular kind of
ideal for the library which I think most
of us would share but it hasn't always
existed it hasn't always existed for
everybody you know we've struggled to
make libraries accessible to everybody
in society who gets counted as part of
society who gets a library card that
changes over time libraries in the Jim
Crow South excluded people of African
descent from full participation in their
communities store of knowledge and so a
library can be used as a kind of
disciplinary means of control a means of
oppression we do well to ask ourselves
who's left out of these systems even as
we you know celebrate the potential of
the power of these institutions to
provide a space who gets access to it
remains an important question I think
yes taking this brain heart soul essence
of cultural knowledge at the edge and
being able to distribute it widely and
fairly and kindly to people in a
democratized way is so important and I
love how you talk about social emotional
intelligence
yeah and that and that's such a crucial
thing for the humanities to
with the teeth past how many kids
especially in the exponential technology
age okay and then this leads us also you
know you're speaking about widenar a lot
as you as you're talking because this is
the complexity of actually what happens
within the library there are students
that come in and learn from these
compress algorithms there are scholars
that write and compress those and teach
them their staff like you said
librarians that know where things are at
how its organized mm-hmm yeah indeed
indeed and for me Widener was I mean
it's you know it was a marvelous place
to end up in because these complexities
were were evident they were apparent
they were layered they were messy they
were rich it's not the only place where
that sort of thing happens you know it's
one of the larger academic libraries for
sure and part of a system a very large
system of academic libraries but it's
something you can find in you know in
your in your local college or university
library your your local public library
system as well you know these things
have different kinds of shapes and
patterns and different institutions but
but they're widely distributed in the
library world and they all kind of have
a history that they participate in
together and then this one was crazy
okay so palimpsest if the history of
writing from Mesopotamia to multimedia
and then you were actually teaching me
about this you actually were teaching us
about this a little bit ago to how it
you you you just didn't have as much
ubiquity and the resources available to
actually be able to write and now
especially in the digital age it's just
everywhere all the time but you actually
had to work really really hard with the
limited amount of space that you had to
write all the way from the days and a
cave wall writing and painting all the
way up and tell pre printing press just
so much what was a papyrus was one of
the major
yeah but iris was an early writing
medium that was made from reeds that
grow principally along the Nile River
in a few other places in in the Levant
and and North Africa a read that when
you sort of pound it out gets kind of
sticky and and lets you kind of roll
these fibers into sheets and so that
became an early kind of paper like
medium in in East Asia people used they
used split bamboo they used leaves of
different kinds in the West people use
the bark of trees they used wood itself
and of course stone has been an
important medium in ancient Mesopotamia
they used clay you know most ancient
Greeks of the early era of Greek
alphabetic literacy probably would have
come into contact with writing most
often on on vases on on on ceramics
where you know early ceramicists were
were using writing to tell stories to
indicate ownership and these sorts of
things so yeah writing has existed in
many different kinds of media and the
book as we think of it now the kind of
thing you go to a book store are going
to Amazon to purchase that has like a
barcode on the back and has an ISBN
number and has you know a copyright it
has a table of contents and an index
that thing is just one way that writing
has existed in the world and it's
important in particular remember that
it's like it's you know a book is like
you know we all venerate books we all
try to take care of them we treat them
well they're also commodities right they
exist in a market system and that gives
a certain kind of fluidity or
portability to the book it also imposes
certain kinds of constraints on on what
that form is books have taken a lot of
different kinds of forms through through
time and what we think of as a book
today is just one of those forms as you
were saying stone and etching writing
into stone it reminded me that we when
we bury people in the ground after they
die we etch into stone so it remains
there for really long periods of time
and also I want you to all
explain to you start explaining to me
before we went on that that when you
have such a limited amount of pay for
your ability to take what's here and be
here and be able to put it into
something that can be passed down that
sometimes you would recycle reviews and
then you can only see it with like a UV
light down the line yeah so that's the
the origin of the title pound cest my
book about the history of writing and
writing systems
you know from clay through to the
digital age and yeah the palimpsest
poundss is a term for a piece of writing
that's been written over subsequently
and it's a it's a practice that emerges
from this context of rarity in written
materials you know before paper was a
mass-produced commodity you could buy it
by the ream or the reel or the roll
it was difficult to get stuff to write
on particularly papyrus which we already
talked about but also parchment or
vellum these are made from animal skins
and there's a whole craft you know and
practice so you wouldn't just have that
stuff lying around
typically a book produced in the Middle
Ages like say a thousand years ago or
750 800 years ago was like a major
cultural production thinking about
creating a book was like thinking about
creating a movie today take a lot of
people with a lot of different skills
and bring them together and make it
happen and so you know if you had
something to write and didn't have time
for that to unfold that process of craft
unfold you might say well this old you
know this old piece of writing that's
some you know religious tract that is
heretical now or you know it's an idea
that's been superseded so I'm gonna you
know take this book this vellum and I'm
just gonna repurpose it take a knife and
scratch the writing off of it so it's
kind of like a messy surface but it's
good enough and then I write out what I
have to share with the world on top of
the old writing of course then a
thousand years passed and somebody comes
along a librarian or an archivist or a
scholar
and says you know I wonder what that
previous writing said because there's
very little often left from those
earlier ages and so by using you know UV
light or infrared light or using raking
light just looking at it in the light
the right way holding it up to the light
you can discover what was on that what
the previous writing said and some very
rare pieces of textual scholarship have
been have been gleaned in this way so
the palimpsest is a is a it's an
artifact of prior knowledge it's also
again a kind of metaphor for the way in
which we layer our meanings our stories
our arguments our hopes one on top of
the other in the long sweep of time you
know and in a sense you know it's a sort
of trope for even the digital moment
it's hard to have a digital pound test
but code often contains little bits of
code from other places
these things are cobbled together and
pastiche iterations yeah right right the
versioning you know in a way you can you
can read you know in a github repo you
can read a whole Marquis ology of how a
project came into being and so it's a
it's a concept that still has some
salience today and to be able to get
behind the eyes of humans that you know
100 billion humans built civilization
before us and to be able to get behind
the eyes of ones from five thousand one
thousand five hundred years ago and
realize what access they had to
knowledge and what access we have to
knowledge now and what knowledge what
access we now have to ubiquity in food
water or electricity and all these types
of things so to have immense gratitude
for that but also to be able to look
back and say that hey maybe they were
doing some of the things right that
we're now not doing right because yeah
yeah I think that's a really important
reflection to it so yeah sure yeah
humanities is one of those ones that
gets you to really consider is
everything that's exponential technology
right now actually completely positive
and good yeah it's one of the debate
topics that I hope gets brought into the
high school and collegiate system soon
resolved the cost of social media always
the benefits and I just hope you know to
really have a long period of nuanced
debate on that subject because there is
so much good that comes from some of it
like long-form conversations of edge
edge thinkers and leaders but at the
same time it can take people away from
creative endeavoring and you know and
the attention economy is a tricky thing
all the way up to trees so now trees
Alliance and entanglement with humanity
from antiquity to present we love
thinking about the interconnectedness of
everything from the roots to the
atmosphere all the animals
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I mean yeah my
most recent book tree is in you know at
least superficially in some ways a
departure from that focus on the history
of the written word of course there's
the superficial connection that's fun to
play with that we make paper from trees
and that's one way we make paper and the
tree and and and writing have long been
associated with each other sort of
metaphorically symbolically
but for me this this book came out of
engagement with in a way another
collection another Museum specifically a
place called the Arnold Arboretum here
in Boston it's a botanical garden it's
on the other side of the river in Boston
although Harvard operates it as a kind
of research facility Harvard actually
has it from the city of Boston on a
lease for a thousand years which is
long-term thinking right but we at meta
lab my research group here did a number
of projects in the context of the
Arboretum looking at ways to let
visitors to the Arboretum experience
some of the data behind the research
work that's done at the Museum I mean at
the Arboretum it's in a way a museum
with a living collection literally you
know the objects I mean I like to say
that any museums objects are living in a
way because they do change over time but
trees really are living they grow they
die and and looking at that relationship
of an institution to has a collection
you know
there are thousands of trees in the
Arboretum at any time but that
collection also has a life of its own
it's responding to the seasons and
changes in the environments and each of
those trees each of those organisms is
doing that independently I was kind of
inspiring and fascinating to think about
so in the course of those projects I
really began to think about what it
means for us to have a relationship with
these organisms that have lifespans far
longer than a human lifespan that that
interact with the world in much
different ways from us that have a kind
of responsibility our role to play in
the maintenance of a healthy planet a
planet that's survivable that really
cause us to pause and think about our
relationships with them at the same time
that we were doing that kind of work
there have been a number of really
stimulating books and scholarship
produced in the last few years about the
kinds of agency that plants might have
in the world that we've realized again
this comes and goes but we've realized
again that these things they live in the
world and they they kind of you know
they have a life they they change they
grow they adapt their circumstances
actually send chemical signals to each
other there is a layer of communication
and action and agency that's often
invisible to us the plants are
participating in some different time
scales with much different kinds of
apparatus involved right the thing that
kind of concerns me about that is that
we too readily then begin to think of
them in anthropomorphic ways they're
right here right it's a funny thing it's
great that is and you know they are not
an audience for us these plants as much
as they're here and they feel like an
audience they are dealing with what's
happening in this space in a much
different way from us yeah and so you
know I was interested in that their
apparatus there and their way of taking
in the stimuli of their environment and
processing it and then making the next
right yeah yeah yeah how they respond to
that it's much different right I mean in
you know it's interesting to think about
those trees and these plants as you know
maybe a season for them it's like a day
for us
you know the light is much more
important to them and also you know they
have this bifurcated world of roots and
an air that are like two different
realms they live in at the same time
there's a lot this fascinating kind of
like you know just cogitate on just kind
of a daydream about I love that
bifurcated realm of roots and yeah yeah
yeah and the root mean of the root
system becomes a really important and
useful metaphor for us to think about
networks and rhizome the ways in which
things are connected to each other that
may be below the surface so they have a
lot to teach us these trees and these
plants and you know you begin to think
about some of the institutions the
Arboretum is one of those with its
thousand year lease but any National
Park or National Forest in our society
today you know it's populated by
organisms that might live a thousand
years and to think that we like presume
to exercise control over them
institutionally politically maybe we
could learn to be a little more humble
from those lifespans of organisms that
far outstrip our own it's a crazy thing
to think about a tree in a national
forest you know in the Cascades that has
been growing since before the
Constitution before Congress enacted you
know an act made it made a law that
protected it yeah yeah it's a it's you
know there's there's something to
contend with there in terms of our own
impact on the planet
that's very humbling to take us to the
multi hundred year time scale of some of
the most beautiful large just majestic
they're so incredible one person on the
show said that the most beautiful thing
in the world was the massive national
parks of filled with the trees and the
diversity there and how they're just
like living breathing organisms of
Mother Earth and and I thought that was
really well said and
and there's just so much that's been
entangled it's so funny that like you
see even in the beanie it relates to
libraries in the paper it really yeah it
released our ability to have
communicated knowledge disseminated
knowledge and then continued to build on
it trees were one of the main ways that
we did that right right right yeah yeah
it's yeah it's I mean those
relationships are they're inspiring
they're fascinating so important to
recognize they have a history that we've
you know come in and out of perception
of those relations over time we've given
them different kinds of weight and
importance over time and you know as we
continue to build our human world on the
sort of substrate of the planet this
human world that that you know is made
in this palem Sestak way of memory and
writing and information and knowledge
sort of layered and interwoven but it
also depends on the substrate of a
healthy planet you know and you think
about a technology like like Vlach chain
technology which you know is is
intriguing for its social and political
implications as well as for its kind of
intrinsic technological fascination it
has a certain kind of instrumental kind
of capacity
Vica see - you know liberate us from
certain forms of institutional
embeddedness politically and
economically and yet and yet it's also a
very impactful technology in terms of
its carbon footprint right and one of
the things that's it's kind of
fascinating to me about the
technological moment we've been in for
the last half century or so is you know
it emerged out of a culture of
relationship with the planet that sort
of expected nature to always be there
and we've given ourselves this kind of
this kind of space to create without
reckoning the full cost and now but
lately we're realizing that that there
is a cost that needs to be
counted for an address and so you know a
lot of the thinking that I'm doing now
is you know actually how to bring these
seemingly very disparate worlds of
attention to the natural world and
attention to media and technology more
closely together and not just to tell
the stories of plants and other
organisms because media is very good at
doing that but what does it mean that
these things inhabit the same world how
do we create a Technosphere an
information society a world of media
that takes the planet into account
that's kind of the question that's its
foremost in my mind these days even all
the way to the maitre terapy that we can
walk through a force so beaches and just
get our cortisol levels drop connect
deeper to mother earth these are very
critical things that we need that we've
kind of lost in some cases with over 50%
of people living in Metropolis so this
is yeah and I like how you looped us all
the way back to the effect that in many
ways that some of the Industrial
Revolution and up until exponential
technology H has had on the way that we
just take the garbage and just dump it
right into Mother Earth no problem just
like short-term thinking is that's not
okay and we're you know we're awakening
to changing that and then yeah let's
let's jump into the metal lab deeper on
that so the impact of digital technology
and humanities and you all you were you
were teaching me and you actually you
know we're slowly starting to get into
this but like just the perception
systems of of plants and animals and
machines now as well like the way that a
autonomous car just sponges in
information from all of its cameras
compared to our cameras just looking in
one direction focusing on one thing at a
time these are all interestingly
different things that we can discuss
figure out what is good code from these
different things how do we merge codes
make new codes that make potentially an
objective function of maximizing
flourishing of society better so meta
lab is in it seems like a very
multidisciplinary
the plenary place a place that's trying
to like kind of probe reality with with
a humanities lens and a while
understanding digital technology I'd
give us the scoop here yeah yeah so
middle lab is a group that started in
2011 2012 it was founded by my colleague
Jeffrey Schnapp who's a professor here
at Harvard trained as a medievalist
but has had a long kind of entanglement
with with the use of digital
technologies and with design in
particular as ways to bring different
kinds of knowledge together usefully
enlightening Lee he began that work at
Stanford with a group called the
Stanford Humanities lab and then kind of
brought that spirit here Harvard and MIT
lab is as as you say a really recklessly
multidisciplinary group of people
including artists technologists
designers and scholars fundamentally and
we're looking for ways to bring those
different toolkits together to tell
stories to make arguments to extend
scholarship to new audiences as well as
develop new forms of telling stories and
making arguments in the first place
so and that work I mean it's a it's a
team of people with students it's a
community that fluctuates from maybe
five or six to twelve or so people at
any one time working often together but
often independently as well on a variety
of projects that include gallery
installation and documentary films data
visualizations that live on the web the
use of mobile technology and it's a it's
a pretty varied set of outputs these
days and then these projects come up
once every you know month or two months
or six months they're on different time
frames depending on the on the on the
sort of the amount of funding we have
and the particular encounter there are
projects that we've been working on for
two or three years and some that are
really much more on I like a two to
three month or it or a semester kind of
timeframe they give us the example of
some of the cool aya project
well one project that we've been working
on for a couple of years now is a
project called caracal which kind of
brings data visualization to bear
the experience of selecting courses for
students so it's an attempt to you know
it kind of expand the scope of
possibility for what you can discover in
the curriculum by giving students tools
for seeing connections among classes
that might not be apparent from just a
kind of keyword search you know
typically as a student registering for
courses you go on to the universities
like course registration website puts
search terms into a into an interface a
very standard interface you get a list
of courses and you kind of like you know
grope your way along that way what we're
interested in doing is using data
visualization maybe a little bit of an
algorithmic capacity as well to identify
connections among courses that might
pique students curiosity interests that
might in particular help students to
remember that there are many different
ways of finding a way to not only you
know an impactful and rewarding career
but knowledge discovery insight that you
may find your way you want to be a
physician you can find your way through
the humanities or through the arts or
through the Social Sciences as well as
the physical sciences you want to be a
physical scientist there might be
perspectives from the arts or poetry
that are germane to your interests and
your research questions helping to
surface those in in the context of
finding courses is something we're
trying to do with with Kuroko there are
also projects though you know much more
kind of artistic or creative vein that
involve kind of playful multimedia or
participatory installations and
galleries my colleague Sarah Newman is
an artist who has had a project for
several years called the future of
secrets which is a in a sense a way of
thinking about what it feels like to be
a digitally mediated human being today
and have kind of record of all of your
written relationships with people in the
form of email or text or other social
media the installation in a gallery is a
computer
terminal you go up to it it asks you for
a secret you write out a secret and it
prints out for you somebody else's
secret and creates this kind of economy
of like what do i divulge do I tell the
truth do I do I lie what do I get back
in return for that yeah
and it's a very provocative way of with
and safe I would say as well way of kind
of mobilizing some of those emotional
responses we have to being digitally
mediated selves
that gives us a chance to reflect on
what it means without necessarily
putting our own actual email into the
equation yes yes this is I love
immersive experiences like that that
challenge the way that we see the world
like you said there's so much that goes
into that do I tell the truth do I not
tell the truth what secret do I get back
how much should I reveal yeah I can I
can I
I believe the statistic was something
like over 70% of people don't trust the
home devices that they have that they
think they can constantly listen to them
and yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we have
human relationships with these non-human
things you know and and and they
continue to you know kind of body forth
into our relationships and yet they're
actually made out of much different
things from us you know like to think
about Siri as an entity with a body in
the world that is a much different body
from any you know human that we
encounter and yet you know we have
exchanges with these with these agents
throughout our days with varying degrees
of kind of emotional affective impact
right so almost as though if once we get
to the point where there is a passing of
Turing test that if it is
anthropomorphised that would there could
be a greater degree of empathy rather
than if it was completely different
looking than humans yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah all different all different types
of weeks now and one more one more
thought with one more it will give us
give us one more thought with
the artificial intelligence that you
guys are studying AI machine learning
how is that going at metal a blurry I'm
looking at that with the digital
communities yeah well I'll say that a
lot of that practice is being advanced
by my colleague Sarah Newman I mentioned
previously Newman is doing this through
the agency of art asking people to
reflect on their emotional and affective
experience of machine learning
technologies and other you know forms of
technology that we associate with
artificial intelligence you know some of
my own practice also involves using
machine learning to reflect on
biodiversity and I'm like training
recurrent neural network algorithms to
give me names for species of organisms
that don't exist as a way of thinking
about sort of the difference between
digital abundance and biodiversity or
natural abundance we used to think that
nature was inexhaustible now technology
seems inexhaustible there in the balance
and an interesting and curious way you
know one of the things about these
encounters with these uncanny
technologies that seem to think or to
have capacities that outstrip our own
cognitive capacities is it also the
experience of these technologies prompts
us to think about what our definition of
intelligence is what our definition of
cognition is what we value what we
ignore in in those terms in the
experience being sentient in the
experience of being conscious you know
the the Turing test as a paradigm
implies and for many of us implies in a
kind of normative way that at some point
machines will become intelligent as we
are but what that means that shifts over
time just as the the kind of meaning of
writing systems or story an argument of
the library has shifted over time as
well and you know one thing that strikes
me about that is that we often ascribe
intelligence to things that pose some
kind of risk to us that we have some
kind of charged meaningful encounter
with
an encounter in which there's a politics
something's at stake you know we have to
agree to get along or we have to or we
have to struggle for for predominance
technology for the most part we don't we
don't have that relationship with but
maybe we're beginning to and it's
interesting to think about the ethics of
that when you know mmm it's not only the
sort of cognitive complexity of a
technology but what does it have at
stake that that increasingly becomes an
important part of our relationship with
with these with these man-made
human-made entities yes all of this and
a lot more into the application of the
humanities over the last thousands of
years through what we're facing in the
exponential technology era I look
forward to unpacking that with you more
on the next time that we're able to sit
down together because that specific
subject how the humanities impacts what
we do in the next hundred years is
extremely important how we can best
embed ethics and morals and love and
compassion into super intelligences and
all that type of stuff
all right and on the way on the way out
let's do two quick questions what we
like asking on the show first question
is are we in a simulation I think way I
want to I want a witty answer to that
and I don't think that I have one except
that if I if I did that might seem more
like a simulation so maybe my own
inability to come up with a come up with
an answer is is an index of the reality
versus simulation that were we're in you
know a simulation that simulates
uncertainty is a pretty powerful
simulation yeah correct it this
non-binary answer yeah yeah and then how
about what is the most beautiful thing
in the world
[Music]
most beautiful thing in the world I
think you know we used to you know when
I was when I was born it's born in the
midst of the Apollo 8 orbit of the moon
when the earth rise photo was taken and
for many people that image became an
image of the beauty of the world itself
I think increasingly we're realizing
that beyond that beautiful abstraction
there's that just that the gossamer thin
ephemeral unity of the whole that that
reality which so coordinates and
conditions who we are and what we can be
even to the point of creating the
possibility for entities that can
transcend it the world is the most
beautiful thing in the world right
that's right I love it I love it Matthew
thank you so much for coming onto the
show and talking to us this has been a
pleasure oh it's been a pleasure for me
to really appreciate you guys you had a
good time yeah you bet out there's still
so much to unpack and understand
especially time memory digital
humanities everything from libraries and
knowledge all the way up to the
interconnectedness of everything that
exists around us thank you so much
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below let us
know what you're thinking go and check
out Matthew's links in the bio below go
and share more content like this with
your families your friends your
co-workers online get talking more and
more about it especially as getting to
the exponential technology edge on the
digital humanities side of things also
support the organizations around the
world that you believe in the
entrepreneurs the artists the
organization support them simulations
links are below support us as well and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon peace